[Music]
[Music]
you did do you look at the kind of view
that gets on peds for hiding your seat
man definitely thing like that dude why
are you hiding over there but where the
horses get their medicine well how are
you hiding my mom's b12 yeah you like
the type of dude that watches film
before he plays dodgeball breaking down
the film before you play freeze tag
yeah Jeff is pretty good he's not still
look at him yeah Jimmy a dirty player
he's good at the tag freeze he's got
nothing on me God bro yeah and his
father was a mime huh
it's just not genetic you know did you
it you look like you cheat at Red Rover
Red Rover really remember that game yeah
god
Jeff damn play it no more uh-oh it's
illegal in schools now yeah again [ __ ]
up
they were got like [ __ ] Antonio Brown
son running a four-four at age seven
into these little white kids and kids
are skinned [ __ ] up dude
well a lot of it too was um a lot of
like they say I read somewhere like a
lot of lesbian children were being like
Red Rover and they would send over like
a straight girl and then try to like oh
yeah honey come over here yeah the Rover
Red Rover send Diane right over yeah
then Diane comes over it's really a
pickup yeah trying to get her work at
Home Depot yeah you're trying to shave
the side of her head and get her to work
that [ __ ] radio check yeah man they
got some a lot of some of those means
rule I agree after you ever notice that
yeah it's mainly the butch ones man
they're trying to go toe to toe with the
dudes that's the thing they're trying to
like yeah they're trying to body up
against the fellas for women get bodied
up bit yeah
they suppress those tits there were
those those they were the wife beaters
but
extra tight so the titties are just
non-existent or they'll put semen on
their tits like to kind of weigh them
down the way I'm closer to there so we
give off that vibe so they smell like
testosterone a little bit and though
he's got beef jerky on him if you
noticed I don't notice that dude that
seems racist bro why lesbos and slim
jims go hand-in-hand
why don't they make something called
slim Jin and it's like just a beef jerky
specifically for for you know homoerotic
women that's not bad I snap into a slim
jim that might be your best idea yeah
that beefy titty taste boy it's just a
slim jim of a tip yeah it's the big
shape of a tip made out of meat in those
slim jims are juicy too I used to take
them and squeeze the grease out I didn't
eat it I'd squeeze the juice your beard
[Laughter]
juice and you put like Cinnabon icing in
your hair any one time I saw Evander
Holyfield at a Cinnabon he didn't see
you did he he probably didn't see you
why you just don't know where he's at at
all time
dude it was really ordered fries at it
onion rings at Cinnabon and they
complain that they came back to cold
well I said until after that well let's
get into some roast mode since we're
already [ __ ] ripping Brendon's chubby
ass over here sorry dude although
recline on your mom about the slim jims
and [ __ ] knows I'm Jenna slim Jenny
here's one Brennan looks like a guy who
wears flip-flops all the time because he
likes the way they spank his feet
little talked about your boys oh I hate
sandy yeah hey it's triggering for me if
you've been bad and you've been bad his
name was Chris it was Chris but God it
was funny I like has a feel looks like a
count a counselor out of a battered man
shelter oh man you just and look it
happens to everybody brother through
this man you're like you you were
getting a counselor in a uber vehicle
you look like the a who always talks
everybody's ear off always give midlife
advice Mike give me the right to [ __ ]
bro you look like a lifeguard in a uber
pool dude hey hands off the railing no
Ronnie why these haters I'm running man
the middle of the summer we were to walk
like an [ __ ] need a lot of those kids
when they start walking that's when the
game ends start looking at this you know
they get them trying to walk real fast
yeah they're like gazelles in the wild
those gay lions pounce on them dude if
you ever seen a young man walk fast bro
God wait wait like you ever see like a
kid like walk real fast yeah what about
it brother blood is like moving around
so much it's too much if you're a child
predator and I'm not dude I do have a
Nashville Predators Jersey but that's
that's holy do it yeah no that's like a
organized affiliated team it's not like
has nothing to do with the same group
you look like the others can a lot of
pedophiles be like hey man where'd you
get the Jersey bro
Jerzy bro like roses hockey I'm just a
fan of hockey dude yeah I mean there's
good you're gonna submit to be on the
catch a predator season seven yeah don't
take my application you keep sending
your resume field we're not doing the
show me also it's not it's not good it's
not good man what do you got deed what a
Brandon looks like a PE teacher and an
adult high school and they're always in
sweats and so serious about anything all
right today we're gonna play flag who
knows how to play flag don't like
capture the flag step ladies crying yeah
it's just somebody fighting on the phone
with her husband that's your only
student brings his kids
it's hilarious
do you like my gym teacher grown up now
I'm trimmer Iike Joker's name was mr.
bubbles really real name mr. bubbles gym
coach and he used to wear San Jose
Sharks hat before they even were a team
really Wow rob was just a fan of what
the animal in the area I don't know he
just used the hotness on the streets and
I remember seeing that hat I wanted it
so bad he's had a shark oh yeah
mr. bubbles dude mystery to me
I didn't jack him off for it yeah that's
why I'm in therapy now probably you look
like a place for a pedophile goes to do
practice laps
bro you look like bindi annapolis 500
bro you definitely look like a play
[ __ ] perverts you look like you can
go to rehab because a girl whistle that
you cross the mass yes yeah yeah
whatever Brendon what else yeah do feel
looks like if Kurt Russell never got out
of trouble with Trouble in Little China
haha
it's also in my top five favorite look
guys look man I didn't you know I didn't
mean it boy you bust Missoula's oh
they're doing all these recreations all
these classics why not big trouble a
little China bro Ohio with Ryan Robbie
came out and nobody gave a [ __ ]
oh that moves are called classic dude
they're trying to make I want to see
some of these groups fight each other
you know
what do you mean like Power Rangers and
like Crouching Tiger vs. big trouble you
know that's fair like I'd like to see
some of ya Power Rangers versus uh you
look like the worst Power Ranger really
yeah you look like the non-athletic
Power Ranger you look like the only
Power Ranger that can't fight losing
costume Parenthood as a book bag okay
the Power Rangers I wants to talk about
it power bottom Ranger
Oxman dude everybody's like a pipe has
headphones on Ana's [ __ ] just dancin
over the only brown power hashtag no
races you gotta [ __ ] jump ropes
backwards only dude that's actually bro
backwards oh there's no brown noise dude
bro you look like a [ __ ] I look like
a shower Ranger okay the only one that
it really needs a shower did you watch
that as a kid Power Ranger yeah I don't
know dude loved it
I was also a fan at some point they've
they've redone it though have you seen
it nothing no one I don't watch the news
there's some new series dropping why I
know that because they redone it Power
Rangers yeah butts on some [ __ ] but
they're not fighting there's meeting up
to talk with other groups yeah I know
they talk about their difference in this
game how to make the world better entry
women right it's awful it's horrible
dude it's not even yeah man they take
off their helmets and it's five lesbians
dude yeah there were cuts yeah they're
not being lesbian bro here's that here's
why be a lesbian one I thought you were
you can still wear the same [ __ ] you
were did you were this exact outfit
definitely like you're their maddest
guys I'm not Brendan your crazy brother
where'd you read that you look like
Rosie O'Donnell sidepiece lunch lady and
a Dick's Sporting Goods
everything you wear came out of a skill
crane you look like somebody who showed
up in a hardhat to work at a skill crane
[Laughter]
to get your apron on and go [ __ ] and
make me a 6-inch sub you are the worst
oh you can figure out when they said six
inch or 12 oh they're not getting that
four inch round every time six inch of
meat oh yeah um an order in that four
inch mountain bro
what did you have anything different
anything [ __ ] I don't know you have
anything that would go with like a
28-inch waist look at a red carpet man
you're out of your mind
they come from a good family listen man
I'm just trying to give you a [ __ ]
sandwich here's an ad from the king of
the sting bro I wear one sock one sock
only oh you got to put on both socks
dude dude you're right I'm only wearing
one sock
you are yeah stance though because it
feels so good I don't need to put on -
oh you're so you're taking a stance I
say they gonna stand somewhere in one
sock oh man they sent me some in the in
the mail hmm dude they look dope
sometimes I'll put a sock on each foot
and pretend like my feet are fighting
each other and fight and then one of
them always wins kind of it whoever
keeps the sock on oh that sounds fun it
is fun but yeah stance is great man
stance collaborates also with a wide
array of artists athletes
cultural icons all types of stuff they
got everything from like your favorite
sports teams yeah men who I got these
new pulp fiction hitters do they have
this Allen Iverson collection a while
back that was tired
Tice story hitters but also they're the
official sock to the NBA never heard of
it bro yeah not bad at all
Stan's also gives back to the community
socks for Heroes which sends socks are
deployed military around the world and
Stan's has a great offer for the
listeners bro if you can hear then you
can get the offer if you go to Stan's
comm and that's easy to spell /k ATS you
get a free pair of socks with your
purchase that Stan's comm s T ance Khan
told you spell it shouldn't be wearing
socks / cats
stamps.com / cat to get a free pair of
socks
limited time offer so take advantage
today go to Stan's comm slash cats yeah
if they're not socks then then take a
stance yeah well if it's not Stan's
they're not soft
yep it's not Stan's it's not socks man
what is that on your feet do little bags
little [ __ ] bags dude time to pay the
bills first of all let me say this
hellofresh sent me a box of meals didn't
tell me so now I have [ __ ] now it
smells like oh yeah
everybody get my way sex trafficking
boats I get the same thing oh it's not
like the Autobahn of sex trafficking bro
so anyway yeah it smells like hummus and
but I will say this when you get that
fresh box and you're expecting it
there's no one better to get it from no
doubt than hello friend cuz it's so
fresh step-by-step recipes for
pre-measured ingredients you have
everything you need and man boom it's
ready say goodbye to go into the grocery
store all the time it's the
one-stop-shop delivered right to your
crib hello fresh got to cover so fresh
you can put your ear up to the meat and
hear it out there walking around in a
field they got the best stuff dude you
could put your your ear up to the
vegetables and hear it being a seed you
could hear two other seeds doing sex to
make it yeah to make a tomato but they
have deliciousness and you can make it a
part of your everyday life if you're
gonna do a date or something you having
somebody come over you got a little lady
a little Swan come
/ to swim in your stream are you like a
pro put a bird in your bathtub you feel
me you can make a meal together teach
the kids how to do a little deal yeah
it's delicious it's flexible you can
turn it on/off whenever you want yeah
skip some meals got skip a week whatever
you need they're super flexible with it
yeah and they got calorie smart
vegetarian and those meaty meaty hitters
if you want yes add extra meals to your
weekly order as well as a bit of my
favorite the garlic bread or the cookie
down Oh cookie dough bro Brendan opened
his wallet the other day was full of
cookie dough so very unique fresh cookie
dough by that so for $80 off your first
month of hellofresh go to hellofresh
comm slash cats 80 and enter cats 80
yep that's right hello fresh calm / k
80s 8-0 and enter k 80s 8-0 trying to
keep lights on if you could read you
know so much I bet if you were straight
you take over the world yeah that's
probably true Jade but I'm not gay bruh
you know what I'm saying dude you feel
me ladies room how does that make sounds
like that to sound tough even though I
don't even have a motorbike whatever did
alright boys I've definitely banged more
busted looking chicks and you have
Brendan no I bet that dude a first boy
he's back we know him it's j-rod j-rod
Oh
can the steam which superpower y'all
think get more chips Wow gang [ __ ] I
love this guy my favorite person in the
world that what's his name BJ
j-rock j-rod boy with you want
relationship advice
yes B fighter uh what is it what's the
problem is nobody's woman like him you
know if he's ready to commit what's the
problem
laser eyes or fireballs which power
would get more girls dude we've seen
this does anybody Cyclops
it's wear glasses all the goddamn time
indoor-outdoor grind head and wear
glasses
yeah indoors now you'll be your absolute
class is indoors is Larry David said
unless you're blind you got to be
throwing fireballs may no don't baby you
can't wear sunglasses indoors you ever
seen the guy in the club but if you're
throwing hey hold up you've seen the guy
in the club usually black in the club
yeah someone likes my and it's so dark
he lifts the shades the rope say the CK
I don't say black guy okay say black guy
that's what I'm saying
okay just some just saying this I'm in
the club a guide you don't be like
Manggarai in the club oh cool go hard CK
don't be CK then I see a job in the ER
I don't know you guys do a New Orleans
dangerous road dude so what are you
saying though I'm saying if you have
[ __ ] laser eyes you're gonna be a
dumbass like sigh I can't hear you with
your skill crazy look your skill crane
running bro go make me a six or it pops
out of the Skrill crane he comes down
the stairs huh yeah we're doing some
work out here like 40 big pink stuffed
animals yeah we got some zoning issues
with the city so all right man fireballs
are laser eyes I think fireballs I think
our sex you could light a couple candles
in the room you know
life of the party while you're camping
think and laser eyes what if those
[ __ ] go off on accident somewhere
you're driving you get pissed and next
thing you know you burn down a [ __ ]
orphanage or something dude also do you
always hear about orphanages where are
they were I've never seen one I've never
said one yeah oh yeah I just make it
right after the orphanage and it's gonna
be a cold just our 14th in Santa Monica
yeah no it's not dude one of these kids
aren't getting help dude because there's
nowhere for them to get help their
conspiracy this you ain't lying wait
more orphanage wait we're all over ever
see ever heard of one anyone my real one
really yeah hello at her house well they
send us that's what they do they set him
to it then these right and just repaired
then no but like no like so a kid would
come in for a day sometimes we in and
they like you need a lot problems how
she makes a living you know watch
problems you go and select and they live
in a big building as a ginger dude mmm
maybe that's just for ginger kids what's
that when that kid was bad it was so bad
they made a movie about it there's a
hole yeah you're right it would be a
documentary yeah through I think it was
a documentary three-part series yeah um
that's so wild dude would into it was a
sigh it was just her and her husband or
what was it yeah her husband and then
she ended up like actually adopting like
four or five of them but
but like I'm talking about I met while I
was sleeping on her couch I made a
million kids ain't were they good kids
so we're all their cool that's something
that some were like baby kids huh they
saw hells they just yeah well were the
ages Oh everything like from from like
like a baby infant all the way up to
like probably sixteen wouldn't infant I
bet cool yeah well if you orphaned
infant bro you just sitting around ooh
do you have a little cigarettes in your
diaper you know babies chillin devos
baby yeah wearing a panty on your head
like a boy Jade uh right there little
briefcase dude first of all shout out to
this guy who made this thing ah dude
this guy's and he's been gone for coffee
what's going on I think you went to
prison for a little bit okay Matt yeah I
think you escaped just to make the video
that's how big of a fan he is Sanderson
oh I'd love to see a 30-second video
just about things that are going on in
your life currently so if you just drop
us that in like a real yeah real soon
like a joke what do you do yeah you do
[Music]
maybe you could be a burglar you might
be doing this on the run he's just the
biggest fan I love this do lamb jam
that's what's gonna be called if you're
on the lam send in a video man and we'll
put it in yeah be people out there that
are ducking charges right now uh it's
tough manly hit a be like a baby dude
how about your [ __ ] Saints I know too
breezy young breezier
young breezy baby he's out he's out for
a while I was up at sorry am looking at
what his injury could be in trying to
self diagnose it that night on the
internet looking at charts looking at
like things where you could like you
know click on it and move it and scroll
and see all the ligaments in the bone
and what did you come up with exactly
what they had man torn ligament because
he just couldn't even move it it was
like he wanted to move it with his brain
and it wouldn't even close and that's
gonna be out for a hot second even when
he comes back to be a little dice it's
gonna be a tweak you think it yeah yes
are you going to [ __ ] this year it's
alright though not a big deal
you never know no I know he could be
getting set up for great for greatness
to bounce back for sure but yet when it
this year with that thumb dude first of
all and the rest what do you know
brother about football man
okay he played in / - mall dude while
you were in burgers okay while you were
smoking crap your boys are doing
steroids at the back of vans on the
highway boys playing football it was a
since I was four okay dude 21 it was a
GMC Jimmy you delink when it wasn't a
van first of all to drive a [ __ ] huge
van when I was a child dude the GMC
Jimmy did with homemade paint on the
side while you were trying to forget to
get your next fix I was catching
footballs yeah okay
the only thing we need to fix was a
catalytic converter do whenever you
decide when you shut the car off it was
like about four seconds later a big
gunshot would come out of the back yeah
so we'd all get out problem
I'll get it right win and win we'd all
hit the ground like it was a Civil War
Reenactment and park my car Bobby Civil
War reenactors house and you'd see them
already yeah and think somebody's trying
to start [ __ ] people thought your
[ __ ] flaming arrow would come up red
natives in the front natives in the back
Becker's uh what do you think on the
flame what do you think what would
chicks like cat I think it's gonna have
to be the fire balls yeah Andy the
Cyclops thing it'll just make you look
like you're dating a douchebag at all
times
yeah you're right Yeah right when Kath
right she's ready Doug oh I know imma
take it that made me think of when we
were dancing I got a buddy who's close
with juvenile really and yeah and he
said he's gonna come on the show well
they saw the podcast and I get and I go
oh he's not dead and he they started
laughing cuz that's what we said but I
didn't say I did I thought he was okay
good yeah he's get over there by killing
it yeah he's killing he's obsessed with
waterparks juvenile is yeah loves water
parks oh wow I just seem at Blue Bayou
yeah I'm Betty's be a probably by I
guess he's just a beast like a beast as
far as in the studio like writes his own
[ __ ] still really is killing it so this
is where you're making up to juvenile
right now
and I'll just say I'm just driving with
her dance I'm like oh we're clowning
juvenile bees actually yeah no no we're
celebrating him yeah I asked what's he
do these days and they're like huh
I guess he's question which was also a
name of a song one of his songs dude
what's he doing would Tim McGraw Tim
McGraw was on there like a mint
immigrant song together with no Tim oh
that's not really oh yeah do you
remember that song totally draw dude I'm
trying to look at some tits bro my phone
right now dude Tim McGraw well Tim
McGraw kinda has tits
well he's 55 Tim McGraw beautiful dude
yeah so is his wife do more beautiful
than him hey Phil yeah oh yeah out of
Louisiana but ah come on dude let's just
slow down for a second why not slow it
down we just go so hard why Tim McGraw
had a do-rag on I have no idea
whatever he's still a fan over and over
again oh man they're so serious you
would about this Vince yeah
god this is the jam this bro meet her so
I can shake you know Nelly bruh oh man a
second of chocolate of singers bro hey
[ __ ] silkie brother god damn you know
is there any never goes away
doves everywhere baby Tim McGraw's the
Hershey's of the country though you know
I'm saying yes everybody [ __ ] with her
why aren't him in now are they showering
in touch in Ohio
not together but do you remember the
time this was a legal United States for
white men and black men to combine
videos this is the Rosa Parks the Jackie
Robinson the music videos you're having
some music video over again now
everybody's doing it Nellie bra way too
serious Nellie man Nellie bra
nothing like Natalie mom never marry so
he's worth a band-aid under his eye
mm-hmm somebody heard him one of that
other guy the guy that the mascot was
playing hockey and in the house and he
got hurt but you gotta know that if your
friend comes over wearing a [ __ ]
hockey mask dude play bro and he ain't
Jason Vorhees bro if you don't kill you
in the first 30 seconds for the axe you
got to know that guys gonna make trouble
around the house what else you got dude
what's the what's the fan say Oh
54% one with laser eyes oh wow yeah I
feel like yeah if you were looking into
God with laser eyes or a girl with laser
eyes and they're gonna be looking at you
and you might be scared all the time
yeah at least the fireballs they got to
get the fight they got to get you know
some gas in her hand they got to get a
match it's gonna take a second you're
gonna be a little bit of forewarning or
fighting they can be like by you
how like we're did you ever play street
fighters kid and watch other kids
Lincoln was the kind of kid that watch
people play video yeah and then I was
just shaving the back now I check the
slots for quarters right after they
walked away and just beat on it a broke
like real quick a couple times spike
mess yeah okay Brittany would pop out of
the skill crane right next door like
what's going over there little buddy hey
kids
yeah we needs a dollar setting that
lunch pail up will ya let us yeah D we
got Davey from British Columbia
this is Davey but I want that whole I
want that 30-second video centered in
j-dub was it his name DJ ROC yeah let us
know what you really get right what you
do just send me a 30-second in what
you're doing
bro make sure you're all right yeah well
you're all wrong brother I don't care
what your brother I just want to know
you see boy Davey from Chilliwack
British Columbia game brother got a
quick debate club question well Theo
considering you're currently getting
into the combat sports and Brendan
you're a form of fire yourself I want to
know who do you guys prefer Bruce Buffer
or Michael buffer both phenomenal voices
but are you more of a desk get ready to
rhumble type of guy or it's time guys I
love the podcasts really appreciate what
you do and love the both year the Rat
King and big brown Theo wish I could've
see you in Vancouver but sadly can't
make it there but keep killing it boys I
love you
Gang Gang buzz buzz buzz gang bro shout
out to voz shots in Canada the new
America yeah um with Bruce Buffer
Michael buffer the same guy did you know
that this exact same guy no you know
they grew up they didn't know each other
we're gonna meet - they're like in their
mid-twenties and they are brothers yes
they're brothers here's the thing about
Michael buffer he went Oh Bruce you had
to do all this work from from hailing
from Denver Colorado 14 and 4 you know
number 2 heavyweight in the world
Brendan and uh he goes on and on and
then the 316 blows his [ __ ] out
sweating Murray has a suit on your boy
Michaels goes oh seven million thank you
thank you I'm out so Michael got the
better business deal Michael Mike
Michael might be the smarter one gets
paid more and works way less but does
Michael still work or Bruce still works
both of them work here God just see the
other day on one of the fights probably
Bruce if you watched the UFC feel he's
the only guy that's my song that's all
of them yeah so he has Bruce or Michael
Michael looks like he maybe not had a
little bit more cloud he gets a little
bit more posse yeah your boy Mike who's
been in movies he does those Hugh debate
it he only does the other thing about
Michael he's a little bougie he only
does the biggest boxing match
I feel like Oh bro will you do this
what's up the SPN nah see I want
somebody uh then I go with the other one
then I want that guy he's probably got a
black and milds in his pocket here's the
thing about Bruce Buffer that people are
now that [ __ ] surface ass off
getting a lot of street fight also do
the splits on you on a dime
really oh yeah also and he'll also go to
Saudi Arabia who go to Taiwan China
doesn't care but doesn't want someone
else coming in on his [ __ ] oh wow
never guy named Jo Martinez but it's
very rarely see him because Bruce is
like Nile no yeah but also Jo Martinez
man he also brings a lot of [ __ ]
violence this guy bought a knife from my
cousin [ __ ] me deal like this main event
is black it's Bud Light so kinda stick
the script oh please he brought a bull
into the ring one time and it's let her
run around for like 15 minutes I was
like oh dude
so everything with Canelo go with the
guy that still has blood in his body if
you can see the images on uh on the dad
once-thriving here's the other thing
about Bruce - man is he yeah he just
he's just such a beast man he's such a
character
I caught him when I first moved out here
I got him I walked into Gold's Gym and I
in front of I'm not walking in right and
I'm like right and I hear loudest [ __ ]
like it's a real UFC fight Brendan the
high bridge in front the whole gym like
oh [ __ ] what's up man I keep going and I
see he's gonna kill me was he is the -
cable you know like the cable rose he
has those and he has a UFC shirt on UFC
shorts you want yeah and he's doing a
360 he's doing trying to do the 360 he
has just got to get that core Power Man
so when I explode explode so everyone's
like others Bruce Buffer doing the 3
yeah serious about his gig dude what's
the 360 is it the the Bruce Buffer
is the 180th it's the three so it's 20
goes and jumps you know yes he blew out
his knee doing it he did he's doing he's
doing karaoke and blew up is me ha ha 36
the briefie 60 already way more
interesting than michael dude Michael
keeps it Michael just he's too rich yeah
no Mike Michael you rich rich oh here's
the thing
I'm just educating your ass here's the
other thing Bruce is Michael's manager
no yeah Bruce is Michael's manager yeah
huh interesting any other brain-busters
most fanbase and all easily do 1 7 times
7 yeah britain shorts out you're right
Brendan gets back in his skill crane and
[ __ ] cranks it up it still on the
crane huh yeah especially this fan base
Eva like Bruce Michaels is he - he do
you ring them up so much there
wait Michael Ida ripple now Mike Michael
another love would imagine Mike a little
library or something let's get ready to
read yeah all the kids are fired up do
jump Jo Martinez is the one we should
probably hire hitting that [ __ ]
Spanish flavor that Mexican flavor
possibly why don't weigh no possibly
support the podcast here's an ad do be
honest with me bro
like you will but if you found $100 on
the street would you pick up that money
and keep it for yourself in your little
fat pocket or would you uh would you bet
it I'd bet it imma leave you man yeah I
got better but I'd only use my book you
man
I use them especially with NFL season
the UFC is poppin as well I won seven
out of nine but those last two that I
lost this weekend your Saints won me
dude your Saints won me some money
Broncos lost me some money either way
I'm happy because I use my okay lay your
money by the lower baby the Saints will
win every time yeah I wouldn't be
telling you guys to bet if I didn't
think that you could handle it if you
can't handle betting don't bet but if
you can use my bookie yeah the kind of
guy that likes to bet a little here and
there give me six dollars the parlay for
that nine dollar stack it up use your
acumen but I don't use all your cash use
your acumen to make the money now is the
time then NFL is pop and join now my
bookie will double your first deposit
use promo code k 80s to activate the
offer that's promo code cat's visit my
bookie dot AG today you play you win you
get paid yep visit my bookie dot AG
today you play your win you get paid boy
time to buy field more pants dude it
quality matters when you're talking
about meat bro we've talked about me it
needs to be good and he's B from butcher
Bob cuz I got some meat from them the
other day look dude it shows up a box of
damn meat bro my porch it's almost like
having a petting zoo but years later ah
nothing better man the high quality meat
that they got grass-fed finished beef
free-range organic chicken media 200 how
about wild caught salmon
dude I'll show my nuts to a freakin
Japanese fighting fish dude that's how
great their media and all that meat
doesn't have to be expensive either man
doesn't be expensive at all every month
butcher box ships a curated selection of
high-quality meat right to your home Wow
can't believe you pronounced all that
yeah bro all meat is free of antibiotics
and added hormones whoa box has 9 -
about 11 pounds of that fresh meat
listen you showing all that fresh
shipped frozen vacuum sealed so it's
always ready to go Jesus major box is a
no-brainer it's the most affordable
convenient way to get healthy humanely
raised Brandon and yo grill just rolling
through letters and words dude you're
like a Luke Kuechly of the alphabet
right now that's a linebacker for
Caroline there you go and he's got an
engine on a
that's two pounds of ground beef in
every box for the life of your
subscription plus $20 off your first box
that's the deal we got for you go to
box.com slash cats and enter promo code
cats at checkout that's butcher box.com
slash cats or do our shopping then just
enter promo code cats at Chuck K 80s
Meetup someone's got to pay for
Brennan's coffee habit all right let's
go on bra little clown my hound boys
first this is Big E this is Big E and a
little bit about pinging he's a six
month old pug Chihuahua and he enjoys
eating snails and making love to this
teddy bear Wow bro and is that it looks
like that teddy bear looks underage that
he's making money can we get a can we
watch that one more time I want to make
sure this thing has a this live footage
of Antonio Brown just got this live
footage of Antonio Brown and his trainer
I don't know how to go over but I think
he's gonna play this week this is live
she's still looking for that three mil
yeah pretty cool man pretty cool hey you
ready dog hump your leg all the time he
looks like one of those it's so
uncomfortable B they get that dig juice
all over your jeans it's just wet that
red rock is so low it's disgusting the
other thing is I remember in high school
but I'd like gone a date to pick a girl
up and she had one of those dogs you
know you you're just not comfortable
that stuff and you like hey how's it
going talking to her mom the dog she's
like oh
now that it's silent like a little
[ __ ] tape clarity like hits the my
[Applause]
god somebody start a carbon monoxide
leak this family's got it Tony
start working Wow
yeah shut up the dog that hump legs
that's ray
what else you got up next we got this is
Brandon bottles dog Winston this is big
Winston huh oh my dude I [ __ ] love
hound dogs they look so smart
well mm that one looks like it should be
on intervention right there on that yeah
you guys that far left when he looks
like he's falling on some tough time it
looks like a drug dog that uh got too
into it yeah too deep
oh how is that not a cartoon a drugged
up I can't went the other way
no yeah just start sniffing can't stop
this one looks like he's getting back
from Iraq one the right hand looks like
I want to be best friends with it no one
on the right also he's been doing yoga
if you could see how he could sit up
directly on his hind quarters God it
looks cool I love you Jesus for years
man is he tied to a fence board there's
no way a dog he's not doing well in the
far right or far left the middle he's
killing the game I think in the far
right he's doing great duties obviously
you know he's trying to make a gun so
you just respect he's trying to get a
job with the city you can tell that
there is first of all you know there's
always that guy in the passenger truck
of a city worker and he's just sitting
there and you're like that guy didn't do
and usually on the phone yeah yeah least
the other guy drives you know you're
just trying to get one of those sprint
walkie-talkies to work for like seven
years next Oh Jamie you there
all the frizz what do you guys we're
doing we're working bro quit [ __ ] in
the Sun you know these are waterproof be
some idiot just use them for fun all the
time yeah love what do they want a dogs
this thing it's this thing what can't
find love on the internet what what
about in your culture do you guys have
animals like this cat what do you guys
have we do have a know we do have dogs
we don't have dogs that look like that
though mmm yeah our dogs tend to look
just like our people very Asian oh
really you are your cats do you guys
more of a cat culture hmm I wouldn't say
that we're super animal friendly we're
more water buffalo people personal and I
like a nice water buffalo
they're dangerous dude mm-hmm I feel
like Asians a lot of snakes like cats
that's too typical snakes and snakes
dude really yeah I don't know maybe I'm
maybe it's a porno I watch I don't know
but I feel like snakes on the same cabin
my own pet Cobras yes in Vietnam there's
a type of liquor where there's a dead
snake inside and you take shots but
that's where I got from to a pet you'll
get yeah Brennan's ordering drinks at a
[ __ ] at a Petco a morning drinks at a
[ __ ] petting zoo and a double whiskey
dude oh [ __ ] dope would that be if
they had a full bar in a petting zoo oh
yeah I'll take another double whiskey
I'm gonna get all these goats yeah let
me get a couple of paps dude I'm but to
a read a book to these hands over here
hey let me get a Mickey's I'm gonna hang
all these llamas over here what a great
business idea dude I want a hound dog so
bad now dude that's like riff raff man
riff-raff wants to open up a high-end
pet area where you could take your pet
out they got water slots for the pet
they got everything for the pet you know
all kind of stuff and you could drink
relax oh damn you know it sounds like a
park yeah yeah he wants to do yeah
Park great business idea though because
those aren't everywhere dude don't rip
up riffraff you already [ __ ] cost us
juvenile as man no no no juveniles a fan
okay for the record but you'd compare
them Jay Cole and [ __ ] Kendrick Lamar
oh yeah no I never would I love you yeah
who's the best you went hard on yellow
with one day I did not you did no I like
the promise people don't think I like
them because you compare them to
Kendrick Lamar and J Cole I don't know
who J Cole is the shoe place at the
airport
[ __ ] but you know yellow ah I know
yellow race it'll make off the [ __ ]
trunk son in a bunch I just doesn't
canal wolf that hitter boy dude you know
what I'm saying I'm Mario coyote hey
papa
you need to get some cole Haans let's
say you say goals huh dude wearing them
Jake holes around here recognize
britain's driving a [ __ ] his skill crane
wearin Jake holes dude you heard of Jake
Hall
okay whole dude is it a [ __ ] male
porn star the bigger name what else we
got a little relationship advice boys
please dude get me out of this [ __ ]
relationship it's also me advice how to
get away from this this your best
[ __ ] goes how am I get a divorce from
this [ __ ] Muppet
how do you ditch a butch lesbian Britton
looks like a [ __ ] soft crab bro it is
like the softest crab bro he's the only
crab out there without a shell man oh
it's in the shop ever caught live in the
wild like damn where's your cause man
like uh-uh nothing I love him at home
you know what do you got this is a well
here's Yelawolf right yeah this is Greg
from LA as me relationship advice hey
what's up guys Jesus Christ Greg and I'm
looking for some relationship advice so
I just started about two and a half
months ago dating a porn star
yes and she's smoking hot right she's
got long dark hair dark skin all natural
big tits big ass yeah pretty face just
like straight Tommy died she's 22 I'm 32
so there's a bit of an age gap but we're
really connecting inside and outside the
bedroom right so the pros she's really
fun to be around the sex is amazing
she's bringing home girls for me or
having like threesomes foursomes five
sons we have planned this weekend girls
in five somes you're gonna get it
catered by seams you better have elected
back in my bowl about 20 seconds to mind
ergo the pros she's really fun to be
around the sex is amazing she's bringing
home girls for me or having like
threesomes foursomes five Sims we have
planned this weekend if people steal
your [ __ ] stuff too awesome that
scenario could be but on the flip side
of course you know you have to deal with
the jealousy and the insecurity of
having her have sex with other guys on a
regular basis you know train it um you
know everything's clean I'm not worried
about that but it's more just like like
I said my jealousy and my insecurities
like try to deal with it internally you
do things we talk about it a lot our
communication is on point and she's
really supportive with it so I'm curious
how you guys would handle it if you
could handle it
what would you do you know to deal with
seeing other guys on her social media
because you know that she's been
sleeping with and just all this type of
stuff where you said she can separate
the emotional from the sex and so far
it's been pretty smooth but I'm curious
what you would do to be able to like
handle those internal emotions
everything you do love your show Gang
Gang poignant speaker probably one of
the more poignant young and we had sent
in a video Gregory's his name yes
Greg from LA shut up to Greg 32 doing
the damn thing um you want jump in this
one first I you at 32 he's he's had his
fun so he's gonna be open-minded could I
deal with it I don't know it also
depends what you want here's the other
thing I'm sure she's great
I'm off to the sex is off the charts is
the chart Uno's dude he's saying that in
a car I can't eat off the charts here's
the other thing Phi seems stressed me
out dude oh I can't imagine it first of
all I don't know what it that's life
what it means you and two girls working
up and two other girls are stealing a
bunch of [ __ ] in your place that's what
that is there's that if they're on the
hustle or you and two girls that hook it
up and then the other three girls just
on the sidelines ready to get into the
game it's so stressful dude yeah and you
better have hors d'oeuvres you better
have electrolytes and there better be
drugs dude yeah it's a lot of
responsibility but that's not what this
is about
that's not what this is about don't tell
me that I don't know if I could deal
with it because here's the thing you're
32 brother I don't know if you want a
family you have one now you have five
[ __ ] women so family you Charles
Manson what do you plan to do bro I I
probably can Hamlet just goes down the
road it'd be tough for your mom you know
for your kid to look up oh what did mom
do when she was younger yeah turn on
it's a [ __ ] video you know I'm saying
that well fair enough to think about
that you could have sing about them them
having sex on tape I don't think my
people get need Jacqueline on them well
that's what they got to do that's the
big numbers you don't have to they could
just have sex man a good four I like
that he's open-minded I I wouldn't be
that just type if I was 32 also she's
22 and you don't have family nothing to
worry about no responsibilities have fun
dude
and also I'm assuming because she does
it for work and obviously just getting
railed you can do your own thing on the
side - you're ruining this guy's life
can we go to the culture corner let's
get some suggestions from some people
who were probably smarter than us cat
could you handle it if your mail is a
porno star I think it depends cuz on one
hand I think if he's a porn star the
last thing he'd want to do when he gets
home is doing things sexually it's like
working at a strip club the last thing
you want to do is come home and then
[ __ ]
you'd be surprised but yeah I watched
some of it the other night actually oh
yeah man dude thanks one of my favorite
parts I've only watched about 20 minutes
is the acting in the beginning oh yeah
where I'd play all the characters bro
it's walking good dude yeah dude god I
thought about [ __ ] all over me dude the
acting then we're getting this [ __ ]
Craven I thought that the blonde thought
at the end was a little much but she's
hot dog it was kind of cute who's
where'd you taste me do you have her
number
no man hard to tell you it's me anyway I
want to shave her tits a little bit but
dude the [ __ ] character the [ __ ]
guy at the counter of a new order and
the talk okay I know what you want big
boy thanks brother
let's get back into it cat what do you
think about this [ __ ] sick twisted
man who's calling oh no no no I don't
think I could do it personally but
that's if she's 22 she's probably just
getting into this so you got a couple
more years where you got to figure this
out if you're trying to stick with her
it takes a mature dude to deal with this
but also there's there's such a taboo on
porno stars and strippers and stuff I
don't see the big deal with it I don't
see the big deal with it at all well she
strippers right what is he asking yeah
whatever you ask you I think that please
ask me if you guys could do it like you
come over help with the Faisal
cuz that's I've stresses me out dude
really I mean if they want to play like
a pickup game I'm down I don't know what
they're trying to do though yeah I don't
know I would rather I don't think I want
to do that have you ever dated a porno
star I've like been interested in it um
yeah I probably definitely like stalked
a couple of them yeah yeah you know but
I don't think there's anything wrong
with porno stars or anything like that I
just think could you date one though
like I don't know I think it would be
too much sometimes the culture is just
the something that I don't want around
you know like I remember uh it's not a
terrible idea I had a roommate whose
friend was a stripper and she stole our
vacuum once and so it was just like
telling you got all this you know you
got a lot of extras there's a lot of
baggage that comes along with this type
of person the same as like dating a
comedian or something I think there's a
lot of like you know there's a lot of
baggage that comes along with these
people
everybody wants a pit bull - you get a
pit bull yeah it's a lot of
responsibility yeah til it each one of
the twins you know then you're like damn
bro you know where's Lenny yeah you
asked for it so I think that get a pit
bull I think that the 32 and 22 also
seemed a little tough sometimes 22 it's
hard like you have a like a partner in
crime as opposed to like an associate or
somebody that you kind of reign over a
little bit but that could just be me
being judgmental as well I mean here's
the other thing you got to question
yourself if you're if you're if you got
a connection with a 22 year old porn
star yeah I'm saying they guess you
might have to question what's going on
yeah maybe
dude I've met some porno stars blow your
mind not only in the bedroom but also
you know super smart like I said Karen
do you know her
yes she's really really creative yet in
every way yeah and a lot of them are not
though a lot of them belongs typical you
know glory hole girls yeah some people
can't read and they're all just out
there [ __ ] people online mm-hmm so
anyway bro good luck yeah listen takes a
special tie listen yeah I had a friend
who's an open relationship I told him
dude you're a special special type of
dude
to live that life and you stressed out
all the time
I don't know man I don't know how that
issues making me feel erect bro it's
higher do some sweat well a lot of times
when a lot of blood goes into my wiener
you get tired I get tired yeah big dick
but leaves my brain I think but yeah
must shut down
yes Braun come to and I'll just be you
know pretending like I'm [ __ ] most
that blood goes to your ass if you got
that dumper
yes America to remind you I did you
didn't even know how to nice I ask you
piece of [ __ ] buddy it has to be friends
dude I know I will you always hide it
dude like dude get the cake cake cake
cake sounds disgusting brother New
Orleans cakes out this ain't an IHOP
brother you better get on here's what
I'm saying is guy if you can do it
cheers to you man I better man than me
yeah it sound like there's some bravado
winning you know you want to tell us you
got these threesomes foursomes 5 some
dude it's all fun and games so half your
[ __ ] goes missing right you know what
I'm saying
there's no way five people are over at
your house just to [ __ ] and not steal
something all right
dude I go over to somebody's house bro
even if I'm in love with them I might
steal some [ __ ] yeah I'll go through
their cabinets then you see what's up
you how many seen how much silverware I
have from rich people are [ __ ] houses
I went over to growing up bro how many
medications I have next I got about 70
sets bro preach
I always steal from the out backstage
but look also in another part of me is
envious oh you out there you get need
you got that you know you got the
titties and all of that and the glitter
and everybody
you bust their nuts yeah you bust a name
yes we got what do you think D well I
bet you deal with it for your girl as a
porn star I mean she seems cool about it
when he described this awesome girl and
he was being way more of a ho about it
than the porn star well she's a porn
star so what else she can bring in the
day yeah that's all she [ __ ] dude it's
her job bro yeah yeah and it's her job
home bro
they should make more money video shut
the [ __ ] up you don't unfair you'll be
surprised how much little money they do
they don't make any they gotta own all
their [ __ ] Sly James then flip the
script that's how they all do the mic
and stuff now yeah they all did the it's
so sad those women all been taking
advantage of everything that sports
that's everything so yeah there's no
Dare between porno stars and UFC
fighters oh I only one person making all
the money
I agree Conor McGregor oh you know
you're all doing work everybody gets
concussed with a dick to the face or
elbow you're all getting can cause porno
stars and fighters bro I don't know it's
science let's move on is it science when
Britain says its science I think he's
got a google science here here one thing
y'all will comment on this a little bit
further because he did ask he said would
you be able to handle it I don't think I
would be able to handle it
I don't think I would be able to handle
it if it's a girl that I'm really into
if it's a girl you're just hooking up
with porn stars 90 out of six seven
ninety five times it's been it's there
where they're supposed to be their best
it's better seen than not hurt or
whatever it is you know sometimes it'll
bum me out when you meet them yeah it's
always it's it's it's the lights the
camera the action you know you never
want to you never want to meet your
heroes brother it's true man really is
true you don't want to see how sausage
is made
yeah and then you get there like oh this
what they do yes what they do Playboy we
had a pig that was misbehaving a lot of
times when we take him over there about
a sausage maker and show them what the
[ __ ] was gonna happen boy [ __ ] yeah
you [ __ ] look over there Darius get
it located a little bell on his neck
they barbecue sauce I was like an Asian
Bell yeah
good luck man damn there he is calm down
over there he was always [ __ ] local
bruh dude film that buy some see what's
up dude submit it next week yeah bro get
some fireballs dude get some lasers out
of your ass bro and [ __ ] take down a
stop sign in a small town but I'm doing
it I'll give you $40 boy yeah yeah what
else we got we got a fire in this
episode let's [ __ ] keep going Rowan
Ashley from New Zealand more Russia bit
man yeah my king of sting it
uh only one relationship but yeah the
one advice today you guys did a good job
from these Eiland here
Brendan I actually meet you when you
came here and even so early on in your
comedy career man that was so funny I
hope you come back both the oh you
skipped us for some reason yep I'm a
better person I don't really know why
Connor took sting up for you guys girls
with no arms like I was out in town and
I met this girl and she just she came on
to me and she was gorgeous man she had a
bangin body but she had she had no arms
like it was off at the at the elbow yeah
and I just we get the best bang couldn't
do it but oh my might seed do it but I
just couldn't do it I just wanna know
you guys I've done a little sting it
goes no arms she's let's gang game hot
spot buzz buzz Brunning broke shout out
in New Zealand favorite place I've ever
been there in Dublin top - um no arms
listen if it's like that girl who is
that I don't know how she lost her arms
you know I'm saying because there was
that movie where the girl was uh riding
waves in Hawaii and a shark took her
arms that [ __ ] turned me on
took her arm arms really they went chops
right now what the [ __ ] cha oh my god
yeah this one back then that [ __ ] was
sexy damn bro yeah dude but no arms if
they're a body's a body
dumpers a dumper did ya sure now it is
dude that other people have told you
it's nice here's what I'm saying is dude
what is this lady asking him out girls
with no arms you down mm-hmm yeah man
look if
people don't have to have arms dude when
you go to heaven nobody has arms so you
might as well practice now I'm getting
to know people don't bring to the
Dodgers game though a lot of people get
hit with balls yeah a lot of people are
catching them the heads up boom you know
I'm saying there's no no mitt for ya
unless you're trying wear catcher's mitt
to the baseball game
yeah so that's one place you can't take
her when there are billions of places -
they don't have baseball in New Zealand
coming over here he said big Dodgers
fans that's what he said yeah also dude
they're called the Dodgers bro so if
you're not expecting to [ __ ] out of a
ball you're dude the warnings in the god
didn't mean the Dodgers get hit by the
ball explain my god you're so right
though dude thank you brother appreciate
it man sometimes just hit it h-town bro
you know what I'm saying yeah and as
dumb as they say you are bro dude I'm in
h-town well two weeks right no this week
this week I'll say this to you man which
is guys named Benjamin Rowan Ashley o
Rowan that's cool name bro I'll say this
man uh if you got somebody you don't
have arms dude that's great bro you know
and if she don't have any arms and you
have arms then you kind of you know you
already have a chance to be like kind of
like the champion you will you run the
show but also here's the other thing you
can do that cute thing where you get
behind her and kind of do that kind of
thing like she told ya I love that be
fun I'll be so cool man I'd be fun he
could make a baby video for her family
and this she's like guess what we're
having and you're like I think you're
having a school where you gonna go to
juggling but you're havin and then you
go like this baby love it so I love it
man I think if your mates are just gonna
get you to bangable cuz she doesn't have
arms that's kind of bizarre I think yeah
yeah you're gonna get out more dude if
that's if that's the test of if that's
the hope here's the other thing without
arms think how much of a beast she is
what that mouth do girl what them feed
do girl
the bother bro no what do girl she like
a chimpanzee with her feet scrappy
[ __ ] foot
she's a you're a limp changing that
control the TV like this
with her foot think about it bro don't
touch me dude after you say that kind of
a bro
on your feet you're listening to you
just sexualizing some woman without arms
dude I'm trying to help you man I'm
trying to do let's go to cat I mean
Jesus Carole did you date a dude with no
arms hmm yeah I feel like I would [ __ ]
you like he's got a I think compensate
for the lack of arms with either being
really nice or really funny hmm
you got some makeup for it somewhere
else yeah yeah like all [ __ ] where's my
keys and he's like oh I mean my arms and
it's like a joke
yeah and he can't find his el arms or
keys but something's gonna something has
to give meaning if you don't have arms
his other senses gonna be super
heightened so he might hear [ __ ] he
might have laser being the eyes or you
can just hear people talking two doors
down and [ __ ] you know yeah or three
doors down like that band I was just got
three doors down that's great
Superman yeah that for me hit that for
me dude that's just and then just hit it
dude what happened to them I think in
New Zealand yeah there's definitely
obviously pastime too hard to come by
sometimes so I guess if you're out there
but it's also an it's a world of exotic
creatures and exotic types of species
also how she lose arms she born that way
yeah if she was trying to hug a baby in
it like a like a sharp shop or something
if she's trying to hump a tiger shark
well then what are we doing if she is
she lost her arms like kind of her you
know trying to [ __ ] hug somebody
during a sword fight or something then I
would bet on her and that's the kind of
girl that you're gonna love forever ha
dude I remember my girlfriend bought me
the CD in the Airman's bro and then a
day later asked for the money in pair
I'll never forget that her name was
Stacey she said hey you got that 1499
Stacey dude is she 50 years old okay
impairments are my frickin endearment
bro
[Music]
nothing oh god these boys slapped this
is the only one no way we're good huh
they were good man all right what else
we got do know they had though huh back
in the days a good music man sure we're
a Death Cab for Cutie oh yeah god I
remember him dude dude and also some I'm
gonna appendage if you missing an
appendage that can be endearing can be
exciting we had a guy boss he would beat
us huh
busts a guy by us got your first name
was bust know and he had wooden legs
appendages you know bottoms and he would
spray like animal attractant on him and
he'd sit out there in the park and all
these animals would come up easy huntin
bro beautiful in many ways some ones he
would get some of the animals with a
knife yeah what else you got d this is
from Ricardo Camargo whoo nice a black
guy on know this kind of guy odd a guard
though Ricardo know what up the old
Brendan gang gang torture corner what's
up pops
King under sting it for y'all today I
was wearing my shirts a little bit open
from the top
Blanton yeah I don't got chest hair
nothing not even Cuban I'm Mexican and
my a little bit I just think it looks
nice I don't know King under stinging
open sure it's Cuba style
buzz buzz bueno
do you feel aligned with your whatever
it is Mexican Spanish Cuban Dominican
you can't put them to the top it's it's
you you're trained as a young man for
buttons down bro you got to let your
Khorasan out get your tits out get your
ass on man that's why brah that's why
bro yeah well their shirts are made for
you guys yeah you get that you get that
core you get that core a song get that
[ __ ] carne asada you got that
[ __ ] one gold chain they got that
[ __ ] juicy tits hanging out the front
yeah let your heart shine papa
dude you guys have them three buttons
down is like Latin girls with fat asses
it goes hand and hand yeah man I think
you're doing good man just let it rock
bro let it [ __ ] rock sure he's out
bro yeah Chester Papa let get the
nipples out Betty huh you get the [ __ ]
out crying homes keep going make it your
estómago Oh Papa you know dude open
button your pants bro give up on the
pants get some put some cocaine on your
shoulders daddy make a kiss add a
[ __ ] pair shoes at the top bro take
your skin off to room take off your skin
dude no dude you're gonna die for if you
take off your skin you're funny just
stop buttons down yeah man I think you
doing good if you're doing man you got a
Tony know what the ladies want man give
them what they're asking for Papa they
want to see your chorus song chilli so
yeah I like it man I think it's fine bro
that's what you guys do yeah it's chill
man Gang Gang it that's it boys
that's it that's it that's it papa dang
dude you're gone gasps aw hombre he's
headed home dude viola yeah I'm in
Denver this week bro hometown my mama's
come to see me do standard I came to see
you to stand upon it's crazy man I know
it was cool dude a listen-only you know
really I don't know yeah I'm just
kidding um yeah man it was great I was
watching a special is like huh man this
is [ __ ] dope dude you did a good job
yeah appreciate you man did a really
good I can't wait I haven't watched but
only watched about 20 minutes of it
but that's the most I watch with any of
it me too you know I think it hours too
long then I start zoning out a certain
zone and I have a short attention span
even with Chappelle even with birds like
Chappelle our top picks one out yeah it
takes I finish them in in like sections
gang bruh not yours no dude I can't wait
for yours
yeah well you think you're still gonna
talk to me after you blow up after this
special
I appreciate your attitude man oh yeah I
have to dude we have to come here no you
don't have to do anything to us it dude
how about we're gonna be in Pittsburgh
together damn I know it's crazy huh what
are the odds of that
pretty good cuz you do the same well I'm
in Bethlehem and I gotta be in Cleveland
a couple days later so no cities brother
and well apparently one of my five most
the most uh people that that pay
attention to me is Pittsburgh top five
Wow Pittsburgh Columbus New York LA and
one other place Missoula I think love it
man yeah I'll tell you my date so I'm
gonna be October 4 these are all new ya
hit on October 4th Bethlehem PA
definitely Pittsburgh PA the 8th
Cleveland 9th Indianapolis 10th Grand
Rapids 11th Detroit 12th Milwaukee and
the 13th and Madison love and we might
do a little something-something in
Pittsburgh together yeah might be there
knows something that Late Show ah I'm
Pittsburgh October 3rd through 5th for
me but this week I'm in Denver my
hometown and Rose [ __ ] Bronco Broncos
they suck right now but we'll see what
happens water baton to Flacco Flacco oh
I like like I'm taking a lot of flack
Emmanuel Sanders though he's good
they're just not playing well dude we
should have won not by this when this
comes out my new tour 50 shades of brown
all the dates will be on there is a ton
of them
go to the site it's all over it's a new
tour this week I'm in Denver then it's
Pittsburgh then Philly what up
Maura appreciate your brother gay man
gang gang
[Music]